هل استطاع الرئيس ان يجذب الناس اليه ان
يتعاطف او على الاقل شريحه قليله ولو
قليله ان تتعاطف معهم من خلال هذه
الخطابات اما انها لم تؤتي اكلها تماما هي
همم النتيجه بينت انها لم تاتي تاتي اكلها
يعني بقطع النظر ان همم
[موسيقى]
ما قاله كان ينوي ان يقوم به وان يصلح
حاله التي تحدث عنها كان ينوي ان يقوم بها
فلم يتاخر بذلك كثيرا
ولكن السباق اصبح ما عادش السباق همم زمن
سياسي لان في ال 24 ساعه الاخيره اصبح
سباق من نوع جديد لم نعرفه سابقا وهو سباق
اتصال
همم
والفيسبوك والقنوات الاجنبيه الى اخره
اعلامي وبدا التشويه والشيطان بدات منذ
البدايه يعني من يوم 14 مساء وانطلق انطلق
ربما تاخرت انا قلت ان في 24 ساعه تغيرت
سلوك الاعلامي وهو مهم جدا يعني الاعلام
عندكم
السوشال ميديا في العالم عنا احنا ميش
عندنا احنا لماذا لم يخرج الرئيس ويخاطب
شعبه منذ اندلعت الاحتجاجات هو في البدايه
لم يكن موجودا وعندما اندلعت الاحتجاجات
يوم ديسمبر
وتطورت فيما بعد طبعا انا من النجمش تحدث
عليها عن قرب لاني بالصدفه يوم 17
كنت مشرف على اجتماع في احدى الجهاد في
تونس الاجتماع جمعيه رياضيه لا علاقه له
بالسياسه
وزير الخارجيه بان رئيس كلفني بان اقدم
بسفه التعازي الى ملك البحرين الذي كانت
توفى اخوه
في ذلك اليوم او قبل ذلك بيوم وسافرت من
يوم السبت
بعد ما ابلغك وزير
الخارجيه بذلك
اخذت الطائره عن طريق اظن ايطاليا حتى عن
طريق تونس دبي همم البحرين البحرين
مساء يوم 18
يوم 18
طريقه الفازات
الامور الى ما وصلت اليه لاحقا اولا لان
الايام الاولى لم اكن موجودا حتى قراءه
تكون كامله للاوضاع
بالصدفه سادفت عند العوده عدت عن طريق
باريس لان لم يكن هنالك خط مباشر على تونس
تمام وفي باريس جئت في الفتره التي
تتذكرونها كانت فتره الثلوج وعطلت
المطارات للايام فلم اتمكن من الرجوع الى
تونس الى يوم 25 وبالتالي لان انا ليس
هناك طيران تمام تمام
وبقيت المتابعه عن بعد همم
عندما عدت مباشره
همم
هو في تلك الفتره او المسيحه جاءت من ما
نعرفش لانه هو عاده من من الخارج في اي
يوم عاد والله نسيت بالضبط لكن كانت اول
خروج له اظن همم
يعني همم
اجتمع اجتمعت همم
الحكومه في اخر جلسه لها همم قبل نهايه
السنه
لموسادقه على بعض همم المشاريع وان كانت
تلميذانيه قد مرت الى اخره وهي الميزانيه
التي بقيت لسنه
2011 فيما بعد همم
همم ثم كانت هنالك زياره
همم
نصح بها لان من من طرف احد مستجد
المستشارين
لزياره
للمستشفى الذي كان همم
وبعد ذلك جاءت مساله الخيط الكلمه الاولى
الذي كما قلت لم تكن خطاب كان كلمه قصيره
جدا
بس من اين اتاته النصيحه بان يخرج في ذلك
اليوم
والله ما كنتش موجود مشغول من من اتتني
النصيحه او ربما جاءت مبادره انه هو
والسلامه
التي تحدثنا عنها
هل يمكن القول بانه الرئيس لم يتمكن من
الامساك بزمام الامور بسببه هو بسبب ادائه
هو او بسبب المحيطين به هل تهمه البطانه
همم فاعله وممكنه في حاله تونس ان ذلك
تتحدث عن حال تونس وكان تونس واحده هي
التي وقع فيها ما وقع
نحن في ذلك الوقت كنا النقطه البدايه
ليه هذا المسار الذي كبير ولكن كانت نقطه
النهايه لمشروع انطلق منذ سنوات ومشروع
شرق الاوسط الكبير يجب ان نتذكر ان بكل
وضوح كان مطروح المشروعه وطرح على المستوى
الاقليمي بشكل يعني عندما نتذكر خطاب رئيس
اوباما في القاهره
2009 نعرف ان كان في حتى اشكال من من
التهديد عندما نقرا مذكرات هيلاري كلينتون
التي
هارد تشويسز خصص جزءا كبيرا لمتابعه ما
تحب ان تساميه بالربيع العربي الذي تساقطت
فيه كل الاوراق ورايين انه خريف وليس ربيع
كانت تتكلم بالتفاصيل كيف كانت تتابع من
زياره الى اليمن ثم الى عمان ثم استقرت في
قطر للمتابعه وتحدثت فيه عن بن علي وعن
مبارك وعن اليمن على الرئيس صالح الى اخره
وتحدثت
معها مقابله وتحدثنا فيها عن تونس